welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and the falcon of the winter
soldier episode 2 revealed a new name to
look out for
damn it we got to move out now they
found us how much time do we have
none it's the power brokers man run for
it marty
yes the power broker now we wanted to
explain who this power broker is in the
marvel comics
and who they could be in the mcu by the
end of this series so
to help me with this i am throwing it
over to someone who knows way more about
the power broker from the comics than i
do
inside marvel co-host mt take it away mt
thanks eric and what's poppin rock stars
my name is mt
and it always feels like somebody's
watching me
you're welcome for that but that's
mostly because that's what the end
credits of falcon and the winter soldier
told us that the mysterious power broker
was doing to all of us at all times
which is deeply unsettling well
depending on what you're into anyway and
episode 2 proved to us that no
the end credits does not lie as we see
the power broker
sending men to kill carly morgenthau and
the rest of the internet savvy's flag
smashers
almost immediately after they steal all
of his but
not before he sends carly a courtesy i'm
coming to murder you nab text which is
honestly
just good manners and i'm frankly very
proud of him but just who
is this power broker person that is so
willing to kill the cast
of icarly international anyway i mean i
don't know about you but if i heard that
someone were
mysteriously watching me without my
permission i would want to know
one who's exactly this power pervert was
and two if they could just not watch me
as i
attempt to parallel park on a busy
street because it's harder when people
are watching okay
don't watch so let's get into that just
who exactly
is the power broker in the marvel comics
trick question there are
actually multiple
power brokers in the marvel comics and
when i say multiple i actually mean
the biggest multiple of all two there's
nothing bigger than two on this planet
just try and prove me wrong you can't
it's literally scientifically impossible
now the first power broker to arrive on
the marvel scene was a businessman by
the name
of curtis jackson who works on the west
coast on behalf of a corporation
by the name of get this the corporation
who says business majors don't have
imaginations not me i mean honestly it's
probably because evil incorporated was
already taken
and much like the rapper that shares his
name curtis jackson and the corporation
were all about making them fit ascent
because the corporation was infamous for
doing
whatever it takes to make that paper
which makes sense because money helps
you buy
things and things are nice to have
especially if you're a greedy bastard
like curtis jackson
like the first time we see him is
literally after he kidnaps the marvel
hero machine man
so that the corporation could tear
machine man apart and find out how to
make more machine men to sell to the
highest bidder
or whoever follows the power broker on
etsy no that's not nice
that is very not nice but when the
corporation eventually disbanded because
they are losers
curtis jackson decided to do what most
corporate executives do when they're out
of a job
and branch out into the superpower
distribution business
hooray and so jackson launched power
broker incorporated and hired evil
scientist
carl malus to be its head scientist
because the bodies aren't going to
augment themselves now are they
no if the name carl malus sounds
familiar it's because we already saw him
on netflix.com forward slash jessica
jones
mt i'm gonna let you finish in a second
but i want to thank someone who helped
us make this
episode shout out to this video
sponsored tennis clash a free mobile pvp
tennis sports game with high-end
graphics and a fun playing experience
available for android and ios
tennis clash has more than 50 million
players worldwide check out the high
number of ratings and the high score in
the app stores
play live one-on-one matches against
real players in the world's most famous
tennis arenas make sure you download it
free from the links in the description
box
down below to get 200 gems and 500 gold
all right i got paired up with this
player lennar they got a sick serve i'm
gonna be in trouble here
okay lennar is up to nothing but uh whoa
what a shot i'm back in this i have not
been able to upgrade my shoes yet so my
speed
ain't great i got him just missed it
okay good game lennar i gotta work on my
game and upgrade those shoes
tennis class will let you play a
friendly match with your friends and it
has a super intuitive control system
there's some fun strategy involved with
how you play with different characters
and decide what ability you want to
focus on forehand backhand or agility
download tennis clash now for free from
the links in the description get 200
gems at 500 gold for supporting my
channel good luck and i'll see you there
okay mt back to you why thank you eric
and
might i say you are looking quite good
by the way because you and tommy are
straight up
killing it on fitness origins on new
rock stars if you guys are not watching
fitness origins yet go watch our fitness
origin show on new rock shows because it
is hilarious
and amazing and tommy and eric are doing
a fantastic job
curtis jackson's main tactic was to prey
on desperate people
tempt them with promises of power and
then send them to his labs that power
broker incorporated
where carl malus would bombard their
bodies with super harsh special
radiation
and chemicals and whatnot that you
probably shouldn't put in your body
anyway
don't put radiation chemicals in your
body without a doctor's
supervision however if you think you're
just gonna walk into that
get powers and then walk out and think
that everything's going to be totally
fine
you fool you see the thing is with carl
malus's augmentation process is that
it's kind of the crappiest crap shoot of
all time because whether or not it
succeeds
boils down to your genetic material i
mean if you got the right jeans for the
process
congratulations you can lift a bus so
you know
go lift a bus leave out your dreams
however if your jeans don't cut it you
might turn into a horrific
mentally deficient monstrous abomination
that jackson will immediately
throw into a cage or even the sewer i
mean
that would be really cool if you know
jackson brought that up before
people started augmenting themselves but
hey i mean maybe you forgot every single
time
it happens or there's option three which
is an option that i just like to call
you just freaking die which is something
that happened to half of everyone who
participated
in jackson's experiments who whoops
which could explain why half of the
figures at the end credits of falcon and
winter soldier
are shaded in and others aren't and
not only that but if you do survive
guess what
now you owe the power broker several
thousand dollars because the greatest
superpower of all
is crippling debt i learned that by
going to college
but don't you worry pb jackson has got
the solution
for you see jackson just so happens to
have a close
relationship with the ucwf the unlimited
class
wrestling federation a wrestling league
of only
super powered wrestlers how close of a
relationship you ask
well i mean he only supplies them with
freaking percent of their entire
wrestling roster
so yeah i would say it's pretty close so
basically jackson would give these
people
enhanced abilities give them crazy
amounts of debt and then send them to
work for the ucwf
until their debt was paid off it's a
freaking con man capitalism
strikes again a con that jackson tried
to use
on john walker lamar hoskins and two of
their friends
after he empowered them however they
would instead elect to
attempt to become superhero rivals to
captain america with walker becoming the
super patriot and hoskins and their two
buddies becoming
the bold urban commandos or buckies
for short but do you know what's worse
than being conned by some rich butthole
being conned while you're being conned
by some rich butthole
by the same butthole the double butthole
car
because not only did the power broker
put his clients in debt
but he also needlessly got them addicted
to drugs
by telling them that bad things would
happen to their newly augmented bodies
if they didn't take these mysterious
pills that only the power broker could
give them
that way he could get even more money
out of him while ensuring that his
clients would regularly come back to him
to pay off their debts it was some
pretty messed up but with the power
broker
the money is always the mode of man i
mean by giving
his clients debt and drug addictions he
was able to freely manipulate them
and use them however he saw fit whenever
he wanted curtis jackson even juiced up
his employees like literally
everybody that worked for him from his
butlers to his bodyguards
have all undergone the power broker
incorporated conversion process
and i wouldn't be surprised if he had
them addicted to drugs too because
that's just another revenue stream
anyways jackson's money-making and
power-broking shenanigans
would pit him against marvel heroes like
captain america u.s agent john walker
machine man the thing the incredible
hulk and most importantly
falcon with jackson having kidnapped one
of sam wilson's nephews at one point in
the past
will mcu power broker do that in falcon
in the winter soldier
i mean probably he already killed a guy
at an airport so like i'm sure
kidnapping a small black child
wouldn't be out of the question at this
point unfortunately though power broker
jackson was a master
at evading justice he just couldn't
evade the rules of the streets and an
assassin was inevitably sent for his
corrupt ass but right before the
assassin could get through the door
out of desperation pbj decided to do
a crazy thing and augment himself power
broker jackson had
accidentally augmented his muscle meat
to a horrific degree
to the point where he could not stand up
or use a toilet seat
but luckily for pbj xxl that rich
was so thick
that none of the assassin's bullets
could penetrate his muscles but carl
malus even had to create a special
tongue-operated exoskeleton for him to
even move around
but anyways long story short though
jackson did survive that altercation
with the assassin and would eventually
find a way to de-augment himself and
become a normal-sized and normal-looking
man
he would eventually become murdered by
one
frank castle also known as the punisher
because if anyone is in desperate need
of punishment
it's probably this anyways now
some people may say that frank castle
was a
murderer for simply removing the power
broker from the mortal plane but
an argument can be made that friend
castle was merely just
creating jobs because after curtis
jackson's well-deserved demise
there was a very big seat at power
broker incorporated that needed to be
filled and so
many years later a new power broker came
on the scene and this time
he's got a cape i mean okay he does wear
a suit most of the time
but he still has a cape he owns one now
marvel has never really gone into the
origins or secret identity of this
white-haired wide-eyed power broker
sequel but what we do know is that this
new power broker
is way more powerful than jackson
because unlike jackson
this power broker gave himself
superpowers from the jump like almost
immediately
this new power broker could shoot energy
blasts capable
of instantaneous incineration and he
could even
fly up in the sky now what could
augmented curtis jackson do huh
he couldn't even wipe his own ass but
though he may be more powerful than
curtis jackson was
power broker 2 was just as greedy and
ruthless and used the same playbook
curtis jackson used on his clients
because he too would prey on the
desperate
give them superpowers and then supply
them to the ucwf
after which he would demand 70 of their
wrestling
income but power broker 2 wasn't some
old fart oh no
this pale mofo was hit with the times so
hip in fact
that he even developed an app for your
smartphone cellular device
called hench where evil mofos could hire
a super villain to do their dirty work
at the touch of a button
and then he made a follow-up app called
hedge2
that made it easy as balls for anyone to
apply to become a super villain but
that's pretty much the second
current power broker in a nutshell i
mean he's a more recently introduced
character
in the marvel universe than curtis
jackson so marvel has yet to do
a whole lot with the character as of yet
but that just means that the mcu can
just make their own unique vision
for what a modern power broker could
look like and i mean if you think about
it if you really just
look closely especially at the caped
power broker 2 this new power broker
looks somewhat similar to
another flying pale-skinned energy
blasting
caped crusader that could perhaps know a
thing or two about
i don't know the ship of theseus i mean
i'm just saying i mean if you watched
solo a star wars story then you already
know that paul bettany can play
a ruthless villain very well and with
this white vision being
newly born and currently missing in
action it is quite possible that this
new vision could
compute himself a new path of crime and
villainy
as the new mcu power broker now i know
that sounds like some insane theory but
there's totally a possibility that this
power broker in falcon in the winter
soldier is someone we've already met in
the mcu before
but just using the alias of power broker
much like
kaiser soze a villain in the shadows
always watching
always waiting a myth of the criminal
underworld
so in that case the question becomes
which marvel douchebag could play a
shady role
in controlling the distribution of
resources like vaccines setting
themselves to get ripped off by groups
like the flag smashers who could it be
well
a whole lot of marvel douchebags now
that i think about it because
thaddeus ross has shown up as an easter
egg in the end credits connected to the
enhanced
humans act and eric and i have been
theorizing that he could be heading up
the global
repatriation council that john walker
brought up in falcon winter soldier
episode 2.
ross himself could be the power broker
running a side operation
with his control of resources and using
a team of enhanced super soldiers i mean
there are past
mcu villains who are still alive who
have been interested in similar goals i
mean justin hammer was last seen in
seagate prison
a prison that we know from the all hail
the king short that was broken into by
the forces of the true mandarin coming
to september in changshi in the legends
of the ten rings a criminal mastermind
operating out of southeast asia who
could very easily show up when bucky and
sam visit madrapore in coming episodes
so eric let me ask you a question
knowing
all that there is currently to know
about the power broker do you yourself
have any bets on who this will be when
he's revealed i mean are we talking a
new face based on
like curtis jackson or an old face from
mcu path what are your thoughts eric
just because i want this to be true i'm
gonna say an old face from the mcu past
so for now my bet will be that thaddeus
thunderbolt ross will make an appearance
or maybe be the power broker himself or
more likely he'll just be another
governmental bad guy and the power
broker will be an alias for some
other important mcu baddie and this week
i'm going to predict that baddie is
the mandarin coming up soon in shanghai
the legend of the 10 rings but what do
you think
that's a really good point i do like
that idea but for me i honestly i think
i'm gonna go with my white vision theory
because we don't know where white vision
went he could easily
have gone off and lived a new life of
criminal crime i think it'd be fun
if it was a white vision i think paul
bettany would really knock that out of
the park but
that's just me well let us know your
power broker predictions in the comments
below you can support this channel by
checking out our new falcon winter
soldier inspired shirt
anarchy assembled look at this bad boy
you can get this at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow us on
social media at eavos follow mt at
mastertainment and follow new rock stars
and subscribe to new rock stars and
breakdowns of everything marvel thank
you for watching and you don't need to
hide
if your body is wide catch you guys
later
[Music]
you